and he starts like hopping towards me
he's like what's up what's up and i'm
like what the [ __ ] is that gonna [ __ ]
hit me i'm not thinking that he's gonna
hit me yeah he comes up [ __ ] dips and
does a full overhand and i'm like oh
[ __ ] so i go in and i roll out and i
[ __ ] i i stuff the shot but then his
either his chin his head i don't know
what it was but it hit my eye and so
this eye just goes fuzzy it's like the
you know like the tv where it's just
black and white it just fuzz yeah so i
couldn't see out of his left eye yeah
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on
let me tell you something
three years of boxing in five
four
three what did i do this way it's so
hard three
two
one damn that's really really hard
it's awkward as [ __ ]
[Laughter]
this is how korean people do it though
right yeah
yeah
no they go they go one
bro
don't do it
man
so here we have today by a a high
request we have ed
and ed the universe and the world's
collide once again hey guys close your
eyes and then if we talk which is it
yeah hey what's up hey what's up guys my
name is ed you guys have two very
different voices
we were both smokers too
yeah did i tell you guys what happened
like uh so i went to hawaii right but uh
but like a couple weeks before that some
dude [ __ ] attacked me outside of my
gym what yeah so like on on my uh story
i just kind of
so here's the thing i didn't want to
talk about it because there's just a lot
of weird
i don't want to add to a pool of
something where people can take a story
and then turn it into something else
right so because every time somebody
who's asian now gets attacked by
somebody it's like oh they attacked you
because you're asian and this wasn't the
case right so
i was outside of my gym in south
pasadena well where the gym is located
is actually right next to highland park
the area is really nice and i love that
gym the gym is [ __ ] dope
but right outside of it because it's
next to highland park every now and then
you'll get some crazies and just
recently a lot of people have just been
dealing with a lot of insane like either
homeless people or drug addicts i don't
know what pandemic did but they're all
coming out the [ __ ] woodwork right
they migrated yeah yeah they're [ __ ]
all over the place right so all these
spots that we you know seemingly thought
it was relatively safe is not the same
as it used to be so i'm in south pass
south pass if you guys don't know is a
very very [ __ ] uh affluent
neighborhood and so
i'm you know getting my boxing [ __ ]
and for some [ __ ] reason so the way
the parking lot is set up there's like
this half brick wall
i hopped over the brick wall and i
started walking out this way usually i
just go through the parking lot but i
for some reason went on the outside and
i see this dude walking up he's kind of
just like you know walking kind of fast
whatever we're going the opposite way
and he [ __ ] shoulder shoves me like
with his shoulder really [ __ ] hard
and i just turned around i'm like yo
what the [ __ ] that's all i said yeah
right which is warranted i didn't say
like [ __ ] you i didn't curse him out or
anything i'm like what the [ __ ] yeah and
then he says some asian joke about like
eyes or some [ __ ] he's like watch where
you're going small eyes or some [ __ ] oh
and i'm like all right whatever and i'm
at this point i'm not even mad i'm just
like whatever this guy's a [ __ ] nut
bag
and when i said the i'm sorry the what
the [ __ ] came after the the joke that's
what happened so he shoulder bumped me
he says the asian joke and i'm like what
the [ __ ] uh he turns around and i'm like
okay like what's this guy gonna do right
yeah guys like i don't know like maybe
five foot ten some a little shorter than
me it's just like some mexican dude how
old about
he probably was like in his mid-20s
maybe early 30s but he wasn't old he was
young okay so maybe 18 actually
depending on the drug he had a full
mustache
he had his kids around him
but the guy comes up he's like what's up
what's up and i'm like uh okay whatever
and the guy just like he's not that far
from me at this point cause he shoulder
bumps me so he's like probably my
distance from like me to you yeah maybe
a little bit further and he starts like
hopping towards me like what's up what's
up and i'm like the [ __ ] is that gonna
[ __ ] hit me i'm not thinking that
he's gonna hit me yeah he comes up
[ __ ] dips and does like a full
overhand and i'm like oh [ __ ] so i go in
and i roll out and i [ __ ] i i stuff
the shot but then his either his chin
his head i don't know what it was but it
hit my eye and so this eye just goes
fuzzy it's like the you know like the tv
where it's just black and white it just
fuzz yeah so i couldn't see out of his
left eye yeah and i'm like what the [ __ ]
is going on let me tell you something
three years of boxing and kickboxing now
is the time for me to [ __ ] light this
guy up right i've been waiting for this
moment my whole life i use none of it
i was literally expecting this pickle
let me tell you what i did this is what
i did i [ __ ] i'm dizzy because we
knocked heads and so if you guys have
never been hit before it's not like in
the films where you get socked in the
head and then you just eat them and you
keep going yeah you get hit by a shot
you don't see those are the shots that
knock you out so i'm a little like
combobulated and i see the fuzzies in my
left eye i just [ __ ] reach out for
him and i
choke him i kill him with my left hand
and i start shoving him towards the wall
yeah and i smash him on that half wall
like his back left barbarian yeah and
then i turned around and i moved though
and at this point this is where i
[ __ ] whoop his ass bro
i just opened palm started slapping him
you know what [ __ ]
i started shaky slapping the [ __ ] out of
him just wow
no scream no grunt no nothing like a
serial killer like
here's the thing i was literally
slapping this dude like i was a pimp and
this fool wasn't tricking enough
and so i start just
and i had a this nike black windbreaker
on because i use it when i want to sweat
when i'm boxing so he was like trying to
grab at me and [ __ ] but luckily i had my
jacket on
so he just sounded like a [ __ ] you
know like a dj
i just kept slapping him over and over
until he started going limp his [ __ ]
mouth was bleeding and [ __ ]
he was screaming and i just picked him
up i literally grabbed him by his
[ __ ] like shirt here grabbed him by
his pants like
his pants
i feel [ __ ] shocked
[Laughter]
exactly yeah toss him like he was jazz
from the french press of bel-air chuck
him he gets up he's stumbling he's i'll
[ __ ] kill you i'll [ __ ] murder you
you know who the [ __ ] i am i'm a [ __ ]
captain saying all this crazy [ __ ] i'm
like [ __ ] you and you know and that's
really about it and i'm sitting there
just this adrenaline just running
through me right my [ __ ]
hand
it felt like the uh like an acme cartoon
like it was pulsing like it had a
heartbeat my fingertips hurt like a
[ __ ]
because i slapped i think i slapped him
maybe seven or eight times but it was
enough to where he got dizzy where he
couldn't even like start scratching at
me anymore but the guy's like stumbling
away
and like i
here's the [ __ ] funny thing right so
after this is happening i'm sitting here
just like what the hell happened i'm
sitting on that little brick wall just
kind of chilling against it this guy's
just screaming still cursing at me but
i'm like this is a crazy person yeah
he's literally crazy this isn't like an
asian attack type of thing i just happen
to be asian he's a psychopath yeah and
so i'm sitting against this wall and
this lady in this older
bmw x5 does like this u-turn turns
around she goes i saw everything are you
okay and i look at her i'm like you
didn't call the cops
she was trying to get a world star
she was in a car
[Applause]
i would i would have loved that
i asked i was like did you record
anything she goes i i didn't i didn't
get my phone off so you just watched me
get assaulted she was just in her car
with her mouth open like oh yeah she
just watched this whole thing go down
yeah didn't call the cops for me i was
like come on man but to her credit she
probably got shook seeing something
that's for sure a lot of times when
people aren't um used to that type of
thing and they see that bystander effect
yeah it's like oh what the [ __ ] is
happening right now i just remembered i
was like you didn't call the cops
the funniest [ __ ] about the story is how
you're talking about all those you know
training that you've done and everything
you just defaulted to pure rage and just
like
choke and slap and you were on your way
forward
[Laughter]
no but i think i think that's the
difference though it's like you know
when you're doing that type of stuff
it's more so exercise unless you're
actually like doing it like you're
fighting then it becomes kind of second
instinct to you right second nature yeah
it was not second nature for me at all
yeah otherwise just because i've seen
dave get mad and i've seen this movie
i've seen that
i'm sweating okay what's the other time
what's the other day so my brother and i
got into a fight and he was just
belligerent as [ __ ] and i literally
choked him and i did the same thing it's
my go-to move
did you do that to jason too
i slapped the [ __ ] out of jason
it is a go-to
that's what i'm saying i thought your
story was gonna be the jason story that
is right you saw it yeah is there
something about choking somebody and
slapping the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of him i
guess dominance man i'm the alpha
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] funny i completely forgot
about that so that's like the second or
third time i've done that yeah i don't
know what it is but that's like the
go-to assault thing it's like works yeah
because i think you know for you
you're a bigger guy than most people i
think realize right and then so you
definitely have that strength too to
like kind of push somebody when you're
coming with that raw force with the
chokehold and then once you got them in
this what's the most natural
it's like
it's like us getting beat by your
parents it's like yeah maybe slip in
hand maybe subconsciously you knew that
if you balled up your fist you would
have done some real damage maybe yeah
either that or that was the original
beatings my dad used to give me that's
what i was saying
it's my first martial art ever yeah it's
like
he didn't even know he was teaching you
yeah
because think about it if if the slap
was like inspired from [ __ ] we saw in
like media then we would also backhand
yeah but we've never been backhanded by
your parents it's always the open source
i always wondered too is like
i wonder if it's that you know that the
karate kid moment where he had him like
paint the [ __ ] pets
and i just started slapping the [ __ ] out
of him i was like oh this this [ __ ]
works but that's so i hella forgot about
this bro you were there yeah i was there
and and i was just like you know what
i dave dave's upset right now and he
needs to get it out i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna come in after
after he gets some of this out because
if i try to do it now he's not gonna
listen to reason so he did this got a
couple of this i said all right dave
that's enough now
all right that's right
that's so [ __ ] funny dude i hella
forgot about that
that's your move that is my go-to anger
now people know my [ __ ] signature
move they're stopping it's like a big
show just give one of these
but you know [ __ ] like that does happen
in pasadena that
similar situation happened to me before
where i was in my car
and then um there was a i was stopped at
a crosswalk but then there was a cars
next to me and so i couldn't really see
to the left and so i kind of pulled out
a little bit and then people were
walking across the street and then i was
kind of like in the middle of the
crosswalk right yeah so i was like oh sh
i apologize i said oh my bad you know um
and then as i'm turning i hear something
hit my car
like a loud like
and i'm like what the [ __ ] so i parked
my car
and then i come out and then i realize
somebody threw something at me and all
of a sudden this fool starts rushing at
me you know
and then he's like i'm like what the
[ __ ] is going on right now and then like
we basically get into like a tussle
we're like wrestling and [ __ ] yeah then
uh i think somebody in his group like
came and then uh she's like stop you
guys need to stop what's going on right
now please don't do this and then i'm
like what the [ __ ] just happened right
now and this guy like while we're in
wrestling i was wearing a hat he grabbed
my hat and he threw it
and then it was just he was drunk you
know yeah he was just drunk and i don't
know like i guess it really pissed him
off that i was kind of halfway into the
crosswalk even though i apologize like
hey my bad i'm sorry about that
but you know this was in pasadena old
town pasadena at that which is a
relatively nice area so there is that
one place too you know have you been
that place called uh i think it's what
it's not ix i think it's roman numerals
but papa yeah yeah i know you're talking
about that please get [ __ ] ratchet
dude oh red does it yeah i saw this dude
i saw this guy he was like a guy about
i mean like your height i don't know i'm
in the car it's about your hype but this
guy uh i know he's like a trained
kickboxer because i've seen him in the
gym
this [ __ ] is a big dude and this
little dude comes up to him and
you just i don't know what the
altercation was about because it's been
been a while since i told the story but
he was just like yelling at him and you
could see him just pointing at the big
dude or whatever yeah and he either
slaps him or hits him right and then you
see or shoves him uh-huh and then the
big dude is kind of like smiling and i'm
like oh [ __ ] he's gonna [ __ ] this guy up
because he doesn't know he doesn't know
this is a [ __ ] train killer yeah you
know and the guy looks at him and he's
just like mouthing off
[ __ ] low kicks this guy with full
[ __ ] force collapse does he do one of
these words he's caught he goes
he crumbles falls to the floor
i'm like the worst thing he could have
ever done is like a muay thai guy and
the guy just [ __ ] kicks the living
[ __ ] out of him dude the worst thing
that could ever happen well that's how
you know you're in trouble if you did
something physical somebody and then
they smile back at you yes that's right
that's the ultimate death movement yeah
it's like all right something's coming
all these stories kind of is a wake-up
call for me because i was on the other
side of that this week
oh really i was in a parking garage
and i'm waiting you know it's it's fully
packed and this
giant truck is getting out
and i'm trying to turn in since it's a
free space finally but as he pulls out a
car comes up behind and just immediately
goes in and takes a spot and i was
waiting for a minute or two that's the
worst i mean i get out of my car i walk
up to this guy it's a honda accord and i
just bam bam bam i knock on his window
hella hard and he rolls it down and i
say
don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ] i was waiting
there for a while get the [ __ ] out get
the [ __ ] out of the spot right now yeah
but i'm looking at him and he's like a
six foot some big white dude
and in my i didn't think about any of
this i was like get the [ __ ] out of the
spot yeah and then he goes i'm not an
[ __ ] you're an [ __ ]
i was like get the [ __ ] out and i go
back in my car and sit and wait and i'm
like
holy [ __ ] i don't like that guy good
yeah
you're lucky he was a gentle giant yeah
that's such a funny reaction i'm not an
[ __ ]
so i think that's the thing about david
too maybe because you're big but the
other thing about big people sometimes
when they get bullied a lot is probably
because they're also unassuming this
podcast is brought to you by babble my
friends for most of us learning a second
language in high school or college
wasn't exactly a high point in our lives
malamo es muy
that's me mucho that means david you are
the mayor of the town well if you want
your spanish or whatever language you
want to learn a lot better than mine
you're going to need babel because
honestly learning on babble makes
learning a second or third language
super easy because it makes sense
babel's 15 minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go i do it whenever i'm pooping or
right before i sleep and it's honestly
the best learning a language should be
about practical usage with real world
conversations and applications in mind
and that's babel here's the coolest
thing about it too they have speech
recognition technology that helps you to
improve your pronunciation
and accent which is muy importante right
now when you purchase a three-month
babble subscription you'll get an
additional three months for free that's
six months for the price of three just
go to babel.com and use promo code g b
that's an extra three months for free
babble
language for life
i've always happened to because number
one the softest biggest guy always makes
the weaker stronger the weaker person
look better yeah right they pick the
soft big guy and they always try to you
know pick on you because they would have
the trophy of oh i beat up a guy twice
by size yeah yeah but it's like you just
picked out a really soft dude i i had a
similar situation well i mean like
so
i bought a air intake for my car because
you know you know it's cool
and um i was just changing it in where i
used to live uh in the parking lot it's
an open parking lot it's not like a
garage or anything
and um i didn't know that there was a
rule against working on your car in the
lot you have to take it out because they
don't want oil spills oh okay yeah so i
i'm taking out the old box and by now
there's just a big hole now in the
middle of my engine bay
and then the
property manager comes out and then he
just starts going 100 at me like hey you
can't do that you can't work on your car
i'm like well why why not i'm just
changing air filter
i got [ __ ] to do but when i come back i
don't want to see you working on that
car all right stop working on your car
i'm like all right
and then he leaves and i'm looking at my
car and there's a big [ __ ] hole i'm
like well
you know i can't just have a hole in my
car
yeah
but i'm not gonna go back to my old air
filter i'm just gonna keep going yeah
and sure enough he comes back and he
goes off even harder like what did i say
what did i say
like i told you you can't work on your
car
i'm like hey man it's just an air filter
right it's like a vacuum cleaner yeah it
sucks in air it's like you have one in
your car too
he goes
i know mechanical engineering you're
working on your car i'm like this isn't
going to spill oil it's an air filter
it's an air filter and then he goes
i'm going to call the cops
sounds like a white guy to me yeah so i
walked up to it i got in his face this
time and i said you should do that you
should call the cops right now call them
and then he goes i'm not crazy
i'm like that's this is your idea you
said you were gonna call the cops
right that's so [ __ ] funny i don't
want to see any oil in here or whatever
and then he's like you can't yell at me
and i was like you can't yell at me
right and we're just yelling at each
other i see other people
walking around seeing this all go down
and then i'm like what is your problem
yeah why are you doing this yeah and
then he goes because i can you know
and i was like look
you don't have to be a dick about this
right because i'm not a dick you're a
dick
this guy has like no tricks up his
sleeves
he didn't think past the yelling at you
so i'm not crazy
this is the thing too when i was in
hawaii i got kind of upset because and i
understand too because you know locals
are really irritated at other people but
because this it was so impacted in
hawaii they were just sick of seeing
tourists right so
went to a basket robbins just to get
some ice cream late at night so
on the floor there's covet stickers
right so where you're supposed to space
yourself yeah
me and muriel are on a cover sticker our
friend shawn and nancy are another kobe
sticker and so our other friends and
this guy this you know this older like
an older japanese dude but he's like a
local so he kind of speaks pigeon a
little bit and he's just like
i'm trying to leave guys
right can you move and i'm like
but you're not on a sticker
i'm where i'm supposed to be yeah i'm
socially distanced and i'm on a sticker
you have to go the other way what the
[ __ ] are you thinking and and then
afterwards a couple of friends who
didn't want ice cream they were outside
and this guy was just going on a red
like these guys it's coved i [ __ ]
hate these people they're not even
letting me out they're they're blocking
the door and i'm like no we're on the
sticker you're actually wrong you're not
abiding by the [ __ ] rules but the
thing is it's like in my head i'm like
if you would have just said hey guys can
i get by you you would have got the same
result
you didn't have to yell at anybody all
you had to say was hey can i can i can
you move aside so i can leave
and you would have got the same result
probably even a better one it's like why
is it the first reaction for people to
just go and start screaming and yelling
at somebody try something nice first if
that doesn't work that should be the
result of you not getting what you
wanted after being a really cordial
human being power trip it's [ __ ]
crazy it's just you're a nobody but then
here's one chance to have something
some kind of recognition like yes your
majesty yeah please that's a flex
a weak flex at that but it's just such a
weird thing to do i i just never
understand it i'll never understand it
yeah i told that property managed too i
was just like look human to human you're
being a dick and english says the same
thing i'm not a dick you're a dick
so i just said you know what i'm not the
one that has my [ __ ] panties in a
bunch all right yeah and he turns around
and walks away yeah you know and then so
i go to dan and i tell him what what the
[ __ ] just happened
oh dude he's gay
i'm like oh [ __ ] did i say something
homophobic
that's [ __ ] hilarious
i mean it was unintentional yeah just
like looking up stop being so [ __ ]
gay
[Laughter]
because at first i thought it was him
having this power trip over some asian
guy thing because he keeps he calls the
cops on asian dudes a lot wow like all
the other asian tennis why can't he be
gay and racist
and a bunch of the asian tenants did
move out of that place
and then a friend of mine we know him he
called me like hey what's it like living
there and i'm like dude don't happen
yeah i don't i mean he's not
but i just told him what happened to me
and then he calls me back later and he
said he actually applied and then they
denied them wow and this is middle
pandemic when they're desperate to get
tenants yeah yeah but because maybe his
last name is kim or lee or some
yeah [ __ ] sick of these changes another
friend of mine same deal she's trying to
move to a place in culver city phone
call was all nice it was great oh my
gosh we've been looking for tennis
and she sends an application last name
asian last name oh i'm sorry it's it's
already took it yeah yeah you could sue
them for that [ __ ] easy though yeah hard
to prove though you know yeah prove
these nuts [ __ ] that's what i'm saying
i'll prove that [ __ ] immediately man
well let's get into the [ __ ] topic of
the day
since the [ __ ] mics weren't working
in the beginning anyways god damn it we
gotta salvage it we'll just poop up
boost up the game yeah yeah it's gonna
be ridiculous but um
so
people
people kind of wanted me to talk about
this situation just because it was a
little weird so um
shang chi is pronounced i found out it's
not shangchi
it's shangchi
so
shang chi is is coming out right and
people
are giving it glowing reviews so far
they said the action's crazy i heard it
was jackie chan's stunt team okay
that's that did the choreography so it's
pretty [ __ ] dope and legit but before
its release the main actor and this is a
guy that i've met before like you saw
him on jk news uh
the main actor simulu so i read this
article and it's kind of going over
twitter it's going on facebook
and he makes a
very interesting statement right it says
that we are not your experiments we're a
culture we're all this other stuff so in
my mind i'm like well what's happening
with this release right now
is did
the disney say some racist [ __ ] and i'm
like okay
what the [ __ ] right so i read it i'm
like oh this experiment i'm like what
does that mean i go and i look at the
original statement of what he said it
was i forgot who the ceo's name is bob
iger
yeah so bob iger right but
he says this is this is going to be an
experimental thing for us
and he was talking about
the 40 45 day what theatrical release
before goes to the digital right yeah
and
what in the [ __ ] does that have to do
with him talking about what's wrong with
that
well because and so i'm like okay
i met simu nice guy
what a [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] if i met you or not
yeah
this is a podcast we're gonna talk about
it topically and if he wants to have a
conversation with later on you can't bro
that was the most bitch-made thing i've
ever seen in my life there are so many
things that we have to deal with as
asian americans right now where it's
like real issues people getting attacked
on the street
like
like
and then you take this
unless you're a [ __ ] dumbass or
you're just an angry angry like closeted
asian anger person closeted night isn't
gay but closet as in you're you're
[ __ ] just you're just this asian
person that's just been bullied your
whole life
there's absolutely no way you would have
taken that statement
and misconstrued it as him attacking the
asian community that's a reach at its
fight that is the [ __ ] craziest reach
i've ever read in my life and this is
problematic too because
shang chi shang chi
already has great publicity people are
excited for this [ __ ] film yeah why
did you have to do that yeah it doesn't
make any sense and you're doing it to
the [ __ ] most powerful person in
entertainment yeah you're trying to wait
a powerful person
right
yeah
and also to not even be even beyond that
it's in a film that you're starring
that's based with like a almost a full
agent
yeah man choreographed by jackie chan
stunt team
what the [ __ ] are you complaining about
i mean like what you're not getting the
cruella you know treatment you're not
getting the black widow treatment you're
not even getting
you know like you're getting 45 days in
the box office exactly you know to prove
like especially to prove to the world
that how the pandemic is going you know
that's the experience yeah that's
experiment because people aren't going
to theaters last weekend i went to
this shitty [ __ ] movie called
reminiscence
at the [ __ ] chinese theater 900 seat
theater there was four people in there
and this was opening day exactly exactly
i mean the pandemic changed kind of the
landscape of how people consume movies
right but why why because reminiscent's
all free honestly
exactly i just missed going to the
theater i picked the wrong [ __ ] movie
you know but it's like hey if they don't
release it the same day on disney plus
and they have it only in theaters guess
what dude exactly money man it's for you
exactly we're not experimenting for me
to make more money dude what is this i
don't get the logic yeah look at how
many movies during the pandemic went
straight to like the streaming platforms
you know yeah and so it's like dude 30
45 days whatever is
not an experiment because you're asian
because of the landscape of this
the world right now it's clear that
that's what it actually meant there is
no other way there's absolutely nothing
in the rhetoric
that shows that he's talking about asian
people being an experimental project in
film
that what are you [ __ ] talking about
a guy what is it even equating it to
like the tuskegee
they're not giving you [ __ ] syphilis
you're trying to say how much more money
you can make
just just
just the level of fake woke snobbery
yeah and his little title was so
obnoxious like i said just because we
met doesn't mean that you're not going
to get clowned on for doing you know a
disservice to the asian community this
is a disservice to us and i think what's
happening in this case too like he's
kind of based his whole brand off of
nobody finds asian men attractive i'm
gonna be
the reason why people can see that asian
men can be attracted that we can be on
the screen why you who championed you
hey bro maybe they don't find you
i'm sorry i'm sorry nobody finds your
six-pack attracted
dude it's like because he's already
speaking like he speaks for all of us
yeah like no don't speak for me i i've
been perfectly fine that's the thing
though man these days so many people
just want to be like a warrior of
justice you know it's like any any
opportunity that they think in their
mind is an opportunity for them to be
like woke and speak on something this is
a prime example of that there was
nothing to speak on just be like you
have an all asian cast you're on disney
like people are liking what you got it's
helping asians get put on the map yeah
actually
actually
we are not your experiment
it's like what are you talking about why
would you even interpret like that it
makes me almost feel sometimes like
maybe he didn't interpret like that but
he's like oh this is a good thing
because you know i'm the asian champion
i gotta make sure nobody talks [ __ ]
about us it's like you did such a big
disservice and the crazy thing is bob
iger had to come out say oh this is a
miscommunication yeah no it's not a
miscommunication you know he's being an
[ __ ] he needs to apologize you know
bob i heard his private thought like
what the [ __ ] is this one tripping on
right now
what did i say he reads the transcript
what did he say here what is he talking
about gosh i mean it's [ __ ]
ridiculous like why man why because
you're not gonna get to go on the golden
globe stage and have a speech cause
you're not gonna get an academy award to
have like your five minutes to say some
[ __ ] yeah you know so you can say it
right now i mean but what was the
[ __ ] problem dude i swear to god if
he wins like some type of academy award
prepare to roll your [ __ ] eyes
throughout the whole thing i grew up as
a unattractive asian man and so i got a
six-pack to show people i can be [ __ ]
like just please man cut this [ __ ] out
we got real stuff that we have to deal
with and by the way you you can't say
that about a film where you are the
leading main character
where everybody's hyped up for the film
didn't need you to do that you make us
look so stupid it's just irritating when
what it does too when you kind of cry
wolf about this stuff people who already
have a negative opinion about asian
people in general they just sink their
teeth in even deeper yeah and it annoys
me it's just so obnoxious what's the
problem with it being an experiment
anyway
like what kind of [ __ ] asian lead
cast from marvel do we have anyway
exactly how is it not in one way or
another some kind of experiment yeah
yeah you know i mean as long as it's
progressive right the fact that they're
even willing to try it because it's like
dude we've been fighting for equal
representation in media here you go
here's something when we get it we get
[ __ ] like this yeah exactly it's like
why can't why can't we just focus on the
positive and celebrate the positive yeah
and even in this case there was no
negative it was not negative
i don't know what to say and like i'm so
curious about people who read because i
i saw the post right
because i follow him i saw the post and
i just see people below these [ __ ]
sheep going in like yeah how dare they
you didn't even read bob iger's original
statement how [ __ ] dare you just take
this guy's word for it yeah and then
just start bashing this company who by
the way marvel has been killing it on
the representation side we had a black
captain in america son yeah right like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about if
you want to talk about representation
look at the cast of [ __ ] marvel i
don't want to hear this panther right
black panther
yeah yeah what are you talking about was
that not an experiment in its own right
yeah to see how well this was going to
do right they know the next one is going
to be another billion dollar hit yeah
you know this movie's not even out yet
to the general public don't make it
[ __ ] sour for everyone before they
get in right yeah right but it was just
a little just kind of like
self-service-y type of stuff because i
genuinely believe he's a smart man and
he should he knows
if he read that and he was like he's
attacking asian people i'm like bro
you're dumb as [ __ ]
you're not as smart as i thought you
were and let's not forget when we talk
about like experiments look disney's a
[ __ ] major corporation at the end of
the day they're not a charity they're
not doing this on the goodness of their
heart right even if they do an all black
cast even if they do an all asian cast
it still has to make the money for them
to be like okay this works we got
something else too is not even releasing
in china because he made a statement
saying because you know chinese people
said he was ugly
damn for real yeah
they you know
i think he's really [ __ ] handsome but
i think it's based on asian american
standards because the asian standard of
beauty is like that you know no pores
porcelain skin yeah he doesn't have that
so
they interviewed a bunch of asian people
they're like oh this guy's [ __ ] ugly
that's some cool that [ __ ] bro
yeah so he got all his feelings about it
i said that well it's not for the
chinese audience anyways uh-huh so it's
not playing in china oh wow what
so that he just so he also lost a
billion dollars
potentially for disney itself because he
got hurt
yeah what the hell he just keeps running
his mouth like worse than like all the
[ __ ] three larson said yeah like listen
i i'm known to run my mouth too but
listen you're a marvel character be
quiet yeah like it's it's a good look
for us yeah man you've been getting good
publicity like people are reviewing it
well it seems like they like it what's
the problem here asian cast
actually
[Laughter]
actually we are not your experiment yeah
like come on
guys like what are you [ __ ] doing man
and it's also too it's like you got this
film offered your previous work from
playing a korean person as a chinese man
yeah you're pretty you're pretty [ __ ]
good dude are we going to be like hey
actually convenience yeah he's chinese
this is my life
you do not have a common opinion
yeah so why not give it to david
like like nobody gave you [ __ ] for that
like [ __ ] relax man enjoy your level
of success you're successful at what you
do you don't have to keep on trying to
fight these invisible people to make
yourself look better you don't have to
do that
like it's a sign of just being like not
happy or depressed i'm not gonna say
he's depressed but i i see in a lot of
people when they're just not content or
have any kind of gratitude going on in
their life then they've got to find
something to complain about some people
just can't get out of their own way man
you know
like they're their worst obstacles just
stepping on a rake
exactly and like you know as just just
for people to understand it's like i'm
not really like [ __ ] on him like i'm
not i don't have no personal feeling
towards him but that statement right
there as somebody who's been in this
space for quite a while
like
it's annoying yeah you know what i mean
like because like i said we have real
issues we do have a lot of films like in
the past that have made asian people
look bad and i see this gem
and instead of celebrating it he just he
just has to do one thing that says that
services himself first before the actual
mission so now it makes me think of him
like oh you actually don't care about
the movement you care about yourself
you care about how you look how people
feel about you it has nothing to do with
being an asian american and pushing the
whole scene forward if it's not praising
you for pushing down the white man or
pushing down media and all this other
stuff then there's really no purpose for
it it's like everything you're saying is
driving eyeballs away from watching
right right right and it brings it
towards you yeah it's like what are you
really doing here now like i said i
don't know if that's the case but from
seeing that type of statement on a film
that's going to do a lot of like good
it's a little [ __ ] entertaining yeah
and we've seen this recently because in
the next topic we're also going to talk
about there was like this little thing
about aquafina doing a black scent
because she's also a part of the film
and it was on twitter where this young
asian girl was like how are we not going
to talk about aquafina doing a black
scent and making a mockery of like black
culture and in my mind i'm like
you know she's like from like the bronx
or some [ __ ] she's like new york what
the [ __ ] are you talking about exactly
when you grow up in a certain
environment and you're around the group
of people who have the same type of
accent you have the same accent that's
what i want to ask this lady who tweet
because she's asian i was like why are
you not writing this in [ __ ] like
chinese
how [ __ ] dare you with your white
scent yeah yeah
you know what i mean
you better [ __ ] say the same [ __ ] in
[ __ ] chinese and speaking to me in
mandarin or cantonese or fujinis i don't
hear you what are you talking about yeah
so you're just keep putting us into a
smaller box saying we have to have a
certain kind of we need to be honorary
whites yeah right
we need to be honorary white it's like
bro that's the whole [ __ ] problem
here with like asians and their
representation and media like we've
always been this quiet subservient you
know we're at least perceived as right
and then historically you know back in
like the internment camp days with japan
and everything it was like
we are the honorary whites we're just
the quiet you know behind the scenes
type of people it's like the [ __ ]
audacity of this girl it's like how do
you not know it's like so what if i go
to the uk right and i see this asian
person and she goes hello i'm like [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
that's not how asians talk yeah like i
like i swear to god if somebody meets
her in person you better [ __ ] me how you
better do some [ __ ] like that because at
this point how do you not understand
that you are a product of your
environment this is already said and on
top of that too we are on the internet
we're in the age of the internet there
are people using bay area slang in
southern california they're using it out
in new york right people in california
using new york slang it's nuts yeah no i
i had a tongseng who was um he grew up
in india because his parents are
missionaries and he has an indian accent
and he's kind of a pop
do you want to go eat you know some chat
i'm so sick of these asian people
pretending as if they're they could
speak punjabi
it's like that's
the product of his empire yeah
there's formative years there what are
you going to say stop talking like that
well it's just it's just ridiculous it's
absolutely ridiculous look man there's
there it's a fact that existed for the
history of [ __ ] mankind and that
they're always idiots and crazy
[ __ ] out there
that's like whatever hater [ __ ] dude you
know like you know that she grew up in
queens new york and she's playing this
character it was her character that she
played in ocean's whatever what 30 yeah
yeah
ocean's eight right so she plays the
girl from queens new york who's who's
playing you know doing the card [ __ ]
well
young lady if you've been to new york
and you see the card people that's how
they talk this is what they do whether
they're black [ __ ] well you know
it don't matter they all talk like that
so what the [ __ ] are you talking about
this idea that you keep on trying to
tell somebody what their identity is
when you don't know their story is so
[ __ ] dumb dude the last chinese guy
in the other ocean series didn't even
[ __ ] speak english
that's right he just spoke straight up
chinese whatever and everybody just
understood him and that was kind of the
joke yeah but we didn't even know like
we didn't really know what he was saying
without the subtitles right guess what
she's speaking [ __ ] english
about that yeah it's the craziest thing
and like that's that was like virtue
signaling to the max right but there was
other people beneath her who were you
know of all different cultures and
ethnicities right saying like oh well he
was like i don't know where she's from
but i got to do my research real quick
let me let me see and it's like
do your research who are you yeah you
[ __ ] detective woke over here
some people just need to see someone
like that person i guarantee you if
somebody looks and says shut the [ __ ] up
she wouldn't say anything no it's
absolutely obnoxious that's why they do
it online they're not gonna ever call
that [ __ ] out in person bro they don't
got the [ __ ] goal to do that you know
well that's the thing like
i remember when i was first on the
internet right like i was i was on
youtube right i would do my [ __ ]
videos and i would you know just
very heightened ridiculous character
because this these are the people that
they wanted to see on the internet it
was like a me times 100 type of thing
going on right and though i look at this
guy pretending like he's black it's like
this is a black thing
you know but lo and behold you don't
know that i grew up from sacramento
right yeah and what you hear is not what
i hear though right it only became
apparent to me after somebody mentioned
it to get a pointed out like oh this guy
hasn't i'm like what are you talking i
sound just like you [ __ ] the [ __ ] are
you saying you know they're like no you
don't talk like me but that's not what i
hear because it's what i grew up with
yeah so
having to go ahead and deal with that
because uh tim uh tim chantarangsu the
homie he had to deal with that [ __ ]
consistently all the [ __ ] time yeah
but that's the thing man people who
point that [ __ ] out like online even if
you check them with facts like yo uh so
and so grew up in this area that's how
people they'll say no
no people don't talk like that yeah
asian people don't talk like that so it
doesn't matter what you gotta tell them
with like factual evidence they're just
gonna still be in their feelings about
no like you know the homie uh danny
chung he's from philly he has a thick
ass philly accent dude like the next
time i see him i'll be like you [ __ ]
phony dude you are a [ __ ] fraud bro
yeah what's what's the
what's the
term that you have where like black
people in the workplace have to put on a
white accent it's like the code
switching cold switching right yeah it's
like then what is that reverse code
switching saying hey
you you must
sound whiter than that
i was like look at this guy getting rid
of his black scent yeah but even the
idea that somebody has to tell somebody
because they because they they call it
hood [ __ ] right they're like oh hitch
it's black people [ __ ] so it's like all
black people hood like even that's
offensive right yeah the fact that they
always try to put like
and we always talk about especially with
my black friends right like we've had
these conversations too about people
trying to make
black people into one a monolith like
this is who you are this is how you
should speak this is how you should
behave but who the [ __ ] says who right
and so when they when they deviate from
this quote and thing that this young
lady says which is this black sin which
is something that a culture can be proud
of right because i know a lot of black
people are proud of that [ __ ] which is
dope because you know if that's what
they do that's who they are yeah but if
you deviate from that they go oh you
ain't black right it's like that episode
of fresh prince with uh carlton remember
yeah yeah when he joins the frat yeah
yeah right and they said you're not
black right it's like what do you mean
i'm not black just because i don't talk
the way that you do because i don't
dress the way that you suddenly it
changes the color of my skin my heritage
where i'm from yeah it doesn't work like
no it doesn't the conversation is so
it's so old it's so it's corny it's
[ __ ] corny it is and you would think
like at this point in history in 2021
with the technology that we have you
would expect people to be a little bit
better educated and aware of like yes
there are people who might look like you
who have a completely different accent
even if you're from the same country
because they grew up in like asians with
southern accents right
hey y'all
hey you don't [ __ ] talk like that you
don't talk like that dude the
mississippi chinese have you seen it
right yeah dude amazing exactly they're
like third generation chinese their
ancestor ancestors what whoever before
them they went there way back like what
some 50 to 100 years ago set up business
there and now these straight up chinese
looking people have this
accent yeah and sometimes they still get
like weird you know stereotypes yeah
taken to them that's how they talk yeah
no one's in the comments like she
shouldn't be talking like that you know
like
no
how is it so much easier to understand
that because it sounds whiter like
really really white yeah you know yeah
what's the what's the deal yeah where's
the line yeah i i think too it's like
people in this country
it's weird right because we're so like
there's like such a cultural division
because of how this country started and
like the apparent racism here because i
know when you have people out in other
countries they kind of look at americans
as like why do you guys always talk
about race so much like they they they
kind of make fun of us about that stuff
well because our history is kind of just
a little [ __ ] up yeah but it gets to a
point now it's just like now people are
just weaponizing and using it in like
the worst type of ways where literally
when that young lady tweeted that [ __ ]
out and she's an asian-american girl and
she's attacking this other asian
american girl for absolutely nothing
simply because she wants to look good
people want to say the same thing it's
like what are you doing to see within
david
no it's like uh
what i what i think about when we when
we're talking about this is you guys are
you guys aware of uncle roger yeah nigel
nick right yeah yeah the comedian and he
does that that chinese
yeah uncle raja i think you know but
nobody's saying hey that's a fact
everyone's like that's hilarious yeah
because that's how asian people talk
yeah
so it's okay when it's in the community
so that's the thing so if in oceans
eight
aquafina had this thick chinese
immigrant actually you've been happy was
yeah is that better yeah are they gonna
be more pissed exactly she represented
us exactly yeah right they kind of
brought this quote where she says like i
will never do a character with a chinese
accent and that's why she's like you're
a hypocrite because you're doing a black
scent i'm like that's that's
[Laughter]
apples and oranges neither here nor
there what the [ __ ] are you talking
about dude yeah
because yeah no my sister sent me a
buzzfeed article
and it was long and winded it was about
linda dong linda d productions oh the
vietnamese girl yeah because she's big
on tick tock now she already had a
million followers on youtube then she
moved jump to tick tock
but
you can see the difference in youtube
she has a lot of skits she's just being
herself like life like this life like
that or whatever
but now on tick tock though she has a
big character where she's just a
straight vietnamese immigrant
right and there was just all the they
said they sent her messages and dms and
she hasn't gone back to us like
basically why are you perpetrating this
stereotype about asian americans
why are you putting down this character
because for a girl like that too the
only thing she sees is like this makes
me popular so i'm going to keep on doing
it yeah it doesn't matter if there's if
there's like a detriment to our culture
or whatever right and listen i don't
have a problem with asian accents at all
to be honest with you she's been amazing
she wants to do a vietnamese accent
she's vietnamese it's a part of her
culture as a part of her life but for
anybody who calls themselves a comic i'm
pretty sure she calls herself a comic or
she's a comedian yeah right if i took
that away from you still funny
right
i mean
that's the thing it it did work for her
on youtube right it got her a million
subscribers on youtube
and i don't know why she went this route
on on tick tock but that was probably
the only way she was going to get so
many followers on tickets yeah i could
do a video i could do videos on tick
tock of me being a korean dad yeah i
should have blow the [ __ ] up it's so
easy yeah you know how come you know get
the straight a you know i disappoint you
uh asian parents with negative
reinforcement be like you don't think
anybody can think of these [ __ ] corny
ass ideas it's all hacky like we've seen
it before hey new asian creators can i
ask a favor though can you just try and
not be funny
without dressing like your mom yeah can
you try just one video just try it out
what else you got in your wheelhouse
buddy what else did we see let me see
what else do you have right because i'm
pretty sure there's like a thousand
[ __ ] chinese japanese [ __ ] korean
creators out there that can't stop
dressing like their [ __ ] mom like
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] dude like i
get it you do it a couple of times bart
and joe have done it i've done it like
once or twice in a sketch yeah and then
you can be self-aware to be like this is
kind of hacking
like how much more can you do yeah it's
just perfect yeah you're gonna do
regular american [ __ ] but with an accent
yeah
this will get the views watch tomorrow i
do a video as my mom
back to the uncle roger thing i wanted
to touch on that too is uh did you guys
hear about the controversy that had
happened between like uncle roger and
mikey chen the food vlogger oh i love
mikey chad right so when you think about
mikey chen you're like this guy i love
this guy he's so he seems so sweet and
he seems like such a genuine guy right
yeah but here's what happened so they
did a collab together yeah right this
was not too long ago and uncle roger as
soon as he put up the vid started
catching flack from the chinese
community right whether it be the
government bots or actual chinese people
in china because mikey mikey chen's
family practices fan long gong in in chi
which is kind of like i don't know if
it's a religion but it's it's something
that they're persecuted for over there
just like the uyghurs right
and because of that mikey chan has
spoken
against kind of like china the
government and like the human rights not
speaking against the people yeah the
government right he's been very vocal
about that and
because of that he's not so popular in
china but mikey chen doesn't give a [ __ ]
he just does him he's like hey i'm in
america [ __ ] yeah well not only that
but it's like hey we don't hurt people
we just practice what we practice and
believe what we believe why are people
getting persecuted for that i don't
understand that that's basically the
extent of his like what he says on that
and so what nigel did was he immediately
removed the video and then he apologizes
to chinese community pandering to them
right because he knows a lot of his
viewership is coming from china so he
pulled john cena he pulled it john cena
exactly right so there's kind of that
too of like when we talked about china
being like a billion dollar territory
right potentially
pandering to that knowing that you know
the government there is doing [ __ ] like
that but when you get when there's a
slight on kind of like you know the
culture or the people there then it's
like oh i'm so sorry let me let me let
me fix this and so yeah nigel took it
down and mikey commented on it just like
yeah this is basically what happened
that's why it got taken down i got no
hard feelings against nigel i understand
like he has a lot of fans from there he
needs to do what he needs to do but for
me i still feel the same way i'm not
going to stop speaking about it and i
just want people to have equal rights in
china that's all and people mistaking
that for i hate he's like i grew up in
china i was born in china i am chinese i
just want my people there just to have
equal rights right yeah yeah yeah so
that's kind of the whole situation but
yeah pandering to kind of china and
that's the same [ __ ] that happened to
jack ma jack ma said some [ __ ] uh about
like the chinese government
like some slight [ __ ] and then they shut
his ass exactly down here
disappeared for months and they i
thought he died because they've done
that [ __ ] where they literally killed
people off yeah and they're like
multi-millionaires and billionaires
right yeah like people who are very well
known and they just [ __ ] disappear
yeah and so jack ma you talking about a
guy who could give a [ __ ] less like yeah
he was asked jack mob was literally
asked at a conference what do you feel
about your company alibaba stealing
patented material from other companies
like how do you deal with this he goes
i don't care you know he's like i'm not
sure if he has an action like that but
i'm doing it now he goes i i don't care
you know he literally said
you could sue me for whatever you want
i'm gonna make twice as much as what you
sue me for
yeah and it's true that's how gangster
this fool is he says something bad about
like the ccp yeah and also he goes sorry
no but that was the thing there was a
kind of a string of jack ma getting more
and more emboldened because nothing was
really happening when he would say
something and then i think there was a
line where it's just like oh okay you
[ __ ] you want to play huh yeah
well because he's making billions of
dollars for the country right you know
right they weren't going to say that's
why i think that he got more of a past
than most people would right but then
even with somebody like him
they draw the line of like hey man
that's [ __ ] crazy though like
it's crazy how oppressive that country
is where nigel ing who's a who's a
comedian he's a stand-up comic yeah he
can't even say his [ __ ]
you're in the wrong country bro [ __ ]
move the united states nigel come here
look look mike say whatever the [ __ ] you
want
well i mean he's in the uk
oh is he yeah he's in the uk bro what
the [ __ ] you trust me no no no no no no
no he's not in the uk
indonesia indonesia indonesia i think
well that kind of makes sense then yeah
something like that but i mean even
still well actually no he is in the uk
right he's i think i know who he is
indonesia but i think he's based in the
uk now i think so whatever the kid he
probably flies back and forth too it's
like a huge thing yeah whatever the case
is it's like bro come on crazy chinese
man yeah have a little like self-respect
you know what i mean it's like dude if
you i mean people have asked me about
nigel ing like all the times like what
do you think because it's half and half
with nigelling right was it not [ __ ]
okay
[Laughter]
why don't you keep on like abbreviating
the n words
i only know this because there was a
girl named christina ing in my church
right i was like half chinese south
korean okay but nigel ing like people
have a half-half opinion about him right
in the asian community they think that
he's like the asian minstrel guy like
he's over here just playing this [ __ ]
asian accent all the time yeah and it's
his uncle roger character because
honestly that uncle roger character is
like a character that asian american
comics have played for [ __ ] 30 years
it's pretty dated yeah you know but for
some reason people watch it now they're
like oh this is some new [ __ ] because
it's new to gen z
i think it's been missing for a good
decade or so
yeah and i think the hook too is that it
revolves around fried rice like he has a
thing with like just you know
criticizing the guy like he's a stand-up
comic he's beyond just that character
that was just his his claim to fame he
does way more stuff than that that guy's
actually his dad was pretty [ __ ]
funny by the way
um
you know so people feel a little dicey
about him when it comes to his content
you know i
he actually has an accent he actually
has a chinese accent he just heightens
it a little more right like when he
speaks english he actually does kind of
talk like this like he actually has it
slightly there so i'm like you can't
knock on this dude this guy's from asia
he talks like that what the [ __ ] yeah
and if you people are enjoying it and
it's a majority asian audience that's
enjoying it then whatever so english is
still his second language yeah pretty
much first or second i i think in asia
it's it's the first language for him but
it's still accented like because he has
a podcast i'm like oh he has an accent
yeah he has a a a british accent too so
he's like kind of you know this is just
a little smash
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] yeah i [ __ ] like
the guy you know like he's like the the
his character the uncle roger thing i
don't find funny at all but his other
stuff is funny and it's the same heat
that linda's getting but it's like are
you gonna give that up if you're seeing
thousands of dollars right exactly well
she's not i mean like like for her too
she found her niche she's not going to
stop doing it i mean i don't know i
don't know how strong her resolve is if
she's able to respond back clearly she
has nothing to say because she probably
feels that way about herself yeah like i
was supposed to be this content creator
that created like the next level for
asian people but i'm just doing a
vietnamese accent and there's a bunch of
white people laughing at me yeah like
what are you you know that's that's the
hard part right right she's gotta she's
gotta go to bed every night with that
exactly or if there even is that thought
you know what i mean it could just be
like oh this is working for me all right
i'm gonna keep milking this like i said
too i [ __ ] love i think actions are
[ __ ] hilarious like when people do
accident it makes me laugh but it's it's
in the context of what they're doing it
for and how it's done is it an inside
joke that we know about yeah or is it
you just doing the accent just just to
get any type of laugh possible it's like
are you doing the ching chong ching
chang but the asian version of it right
because like i said i use accents all
the time i've done it in my stand up for
[ __ ] years but it's about stuff that
i grew up with and then it's few and far
between but if you take the accent out
of my my stand-up set i'm still good
yeah i still got 90 of my material isn't
that no that's the the thing about the
kind of comics and even what i respect
about you is that you don't have to be
asian funny you can just be [ __ ]
funny yeah you know you don't need any
other it's it's not a [ __ ] anchor for
you you know kim jong-il you did it what
three times yeah you know like it's not
like
that wherever that slap in the face that
[ __ ] [ __ ] the slapping in the face it's
always been there bro
again
it all ties back to them
slapping people man
in the face my [ __ ] even when he's
joking he's slapping people in the face
i know dude
tried and true my first martial art dude
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast we hope you
enjoyed the episode the double ed
episode it was fan [ __ ] tastic i
deliver and they are here you can find
ed
[Laughter]
everywhere else and remember if you
could see the shirts the hat cop secret
society uh secret society is a clothing
man that we started it's a fashion basis
for everybody it's honestly the [ __ ]
that i wear all the time because people
just don't make clothes i want to wear
so
here we go that's what we got so we'll
see you all next time
peace